I think it's this is where most people
fail right away with a youtube channel
you can go super niche and and be all
about jelly beans or you could be a
day-in-the-life vlog if you want to
succeed here you've got a shot for work
every single day
what's that belief nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I want to see that amazing thing that
you've got inside here get poured out
into the universe that have a positive
impact for yourself for the friends for
your community and the people around you
and hope that these videos are helping
play a small part along your journey so
I started the making eight series to try
to learn from people in a specific
industry to try to learn from them to
apply some other lessons to help us get
to where we want to go and so today
we're going to learn how to make it as a
youtuber tip number one is start with
what you have with PewDiePie I want to
start on the equipment because I think
it's this is where most people fail
right away I see so many people get
really angry about this one because they
bottle this expensive equipment and they
they come to me like what are the
subscribers where are all the views I've
got I spent all this money on all this
equipment I always say don't spend money
on equipment it doesn't have to be
expensive at all and I think a lot of
people wait with starting videos because
they don't have all the equipment I
think it takes practice to make videos
and I think it doesn't hurt to get
started with what you have I didn't have
a webcam when I started I had a I legit
use this microphone which I actually
didn't accidentally broke that's my
first microphone on the Razr headphones
and it was fine it really was it
definitely doesn't hurt to have nice
quality don't get me wrong but it's not
automatically going to make you get
subscribers tip number two is commit
fully with Gary Vaynerchuk with a
YouTube channel you can go super nation
and be all about jelly beans or you
could be day-in-the-life vlog I think at
the end of the day both work I think you
just need to know yourself if you have
something that you're super hardcore
expert piece in that you have you have
super hardcore expertise in or super
hardcore passion well then that's
something that you'd want to talk about
next 5-10 years then I'm comfortable
with with niche but I think people are
always trying to find which one is
better and the truth is or is is that
it's better based on the person there's
no general answer it's more predicated
on you right look what what feels right
to you how long have you been doing it
good you know what I'm gonna say for
munch is just not enough time to decide
if this is right or not right keep
trying different things and really if
you want to win as a vlogger you know
it's funny every fifteen-year-old and
now every 30 year old in the world wants
to be an influencer or you know or or a
YouTube celebrity right and the reality
is is if that's true I think the reason
everybody wants to do that is because
it's a awesome life right and so if
that's true if that's what one wants I
don't understand how people are not
committed to doing it every day for 18
to 24 months before they even begin to
doubt should I jump off this like the
thought of like jumping off early on
something that is so amazing right I
think it's more about you interacting
with them
when you have a small following so you
shouldn't message a direct message every
single person every single person
watching my vlog right now if they have
300 or less people following them on
Instagram tonight they should DM every
single person and say thank you for
following me what are you following me
for and this is there anything I can do
for you that's the quickest way to go
from 300 to 800 putting out content is
the cost of entry for major upside in
the game in my opinion and then you just
gotta hope it's interesting entertaining
makes people escape and educates them
motivates them you know I think the
reason I work is I think I educate
people I think I definitely motivate
people and I think I entertain people I
think that's you know when you think
about the three pillars if you've
actually got I'm sure I probably over
index and motivation and maybe a little
less than entertainment and really
really great in education and so you
know but there's a lot of people that
don't do any of those three things and
that's why nobody watches them tip
number three is post more frequently
with myself and Casey nice that I saw a
huge jump in my subscribers in my views
in my revenue when I went from making
one video week to a video a day a
massive jump YouTube seems to really
really really care about upload
frequency especially right now I saw
another massive jump going from one
video a day to two videos of the day and
I'm at three videos a day most days and
there was a little bit of a jump between
two and three is a little bit of a jump
so I would say if you're one video day
or two videos a day you're getting the
maximum leverage out of it and then it
starts to fall off now that may not be
possible for you right now you may be
look at that said this is crazy like
making a video a month is hard enough
for me that's okay to be where you are
right now I would look at how do I start
to increase my frequency with the goal
of getting to one video a day at least
one video day should be the new bare
minimum if you want to have success in
2017 as a YouTube creator if you look at
my channel if you look at gira B's
channel if you look at Grant Cardone
Channel if you look at a lot of
different YouTube creators they saw
their growth just explode when they went
to making daily content it's just
something that YouTube carries a boat
right now may not be the same case in a
year or two years from now but
now if you are making daily content even
if it's worse content than your
competitors you will win because it's
what YouTube favors at the moment before
I started vlogging at a YouTube channel
for five years and in those five years I
had a whole bunch of huge viral hits
movies that got 15 16 million views
well my subscriber growth was anemic the
channel growth is anemic flat like that
five years five hundred thousand
subscribers then I started uploading
daily and in five months I had five
hundred thousand more subscribers that's
1 million subscribers five years for the
first 500 thousand five months for the
second 500,000 so I kept uploading and
two months later I had another half a
million subscribers now Here I am
one year after doing daily uploads and
I've got two and a half million
subscribers YouTube isn't Hollywood
I'm not Stanley Kubrick you can't
succeed here if you're uploading once a
month if you want to succeed here you've
got to show up for work every single day
tip number four is promote appropriately
with Roberto Blake the way that you grow
YouTube channel from zero is gonna come
down to getting people to watch your
videos and be interested in and this is
my meme promoting don't go into other
people's YouTube comments and promote
and tell them to sub to your channel
that's rude it's disrespectful and
people are just going to delete your
comment and block you at least I know I
am and if you're lucky I will ban you
forever so that matters what you can do
and what you should do is individually
one by one find people who would care
about the thing that you're talking
about build a relationship with them and
then ask them to check out your video
and to tell them tell you how they feel
about it that could be a great way to do
it
you can also build a Facebook group or
community and you can share your videos
there you can go to existing Facebook
communities ask the admin if it's okay
to share a video on occasion
do not be spammy about it do not be
tempted to try to get as many views and
subscribers as you can as early on
understand you have to earn it and you
have to build it and just remember
marques Brownlee mkbhd biggest tech
youtuber of all time like almost 4
million subscribers you did a 100 videos
to get 78 subscribers so don't be soft
and whine about you did 15 videos 20
videos 30 videos you worked hard a
hundred videos to get 78 subscribers
that's work that's why it takes bottom
line
so again promote appropriately use other
social media platforms you're gonna have
to build those relationships one by one
is the virtual equivalent of knocking
door-to-door I mean that's just how it
works that's something that yep there is
really take seriously and you have to be
committed to obviously you can also
encourage the people who are watching
your content and commenting encourage
them to share with other people that
they think would enjoy tip number five
is be prepared to work hard with Lilly
Singh when youtubers aren't working they
work some more a lot of people fail to
realize that when youtubers make youtube
their career YouTube is their life and
the reason is because youtubers are
self-made there is no president or CEO
giving us directions on what to do we
are that CEO so when we're not uploading
videos we're on conference calls we're
taking meetings doing whatever we can to
grow and be better and for a lot of
youtubers this results and our friends
and family is getting really frustrated
because we're so busy but we have to put
our all into our career or else it will
go nowhere tip number six is do some
research with Derral Eve's don't you
slap up videos to your channel take some
needed time and do some research ask
these questions
what is your channel really about who is
your target audience where is your
target audience actually congregating
outside of YouTube why would your target
audience be interested in your video
content and also your channel and how
can you get the viewer or potential
viewer to subscribe and share the video
find out what blogs forums Facebook
groups Google+ communities websites
people that are really interested in
your content
now recon is really really important
over 75% of my video views come from
outside of YouTube now think about that
for a moment it's really important to do
recon and tip number seven is evaluate
and repeat with Tim Schmoyer and then
number seven and this is so important
guys is to evaluate the progress you've
made the things that you're learning
from your audience and the content the
process everything like just learn
evaluates and then fix things like
what's working poorly that I need to fix
what's working great that I need to
learn from and keep doing and then go
back and rinse and repeating that and
implementing those updates and those
changes that you're making your content
all the time especially if this is your
first time you've ever done there's a
lot of lessons to learn a lot of
experiments to be had a lot of mistakes
to be made and so make them
and but learn from them and then keep
going thank you guys so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed I'd love to
know what did you think of this video
which lesson are you going to
immediately apply somehow to your
YouTube business leave it down the
comments below also is there an 8 9 10
that you want to add to the list or is
there a different making it video a new
part of the series that you want to add
making it as a what what do you guys
want to see leave it down in the
comments below I'm really excited to see
what you have to say thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon the most
important word ever if you had to think
of one word that's most important to you
or that sums you up or that would be -
like a little beacon hey believe nation
if you want to know what the most
important one word is for Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am
and Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details
[Music]